our next headline also from football but
real football how would they get paid
yeah I mean college Ibaka don't have a
real contract the you know the owners
can break anytime it's kind of it's a
little bit like slavery but not as much
as college football like all right
college football fan like grow up Peter
Pan why you know what why don't you
watch the best of the best who advanced
to the other league in aren't some kind
of shady slave labor as a I would rather
watch the best of the best in any
football game have you ever seen the
movie the best of the best with Eric
Roberts and James Earl Jones as the
coach of America's Taekwondo team I
you not
it's one of the best movies ever also
Chris Penn Chris Penn is in it and at
one point before a bar fight Chris Penn
sits his way of having fun with his
friends he sit he leans up against the
wall next to women's bathroom and his
woman walking to the bathroom he goes
number one or number two oh my god
that's picot move it does not work but
it makes him it makes him charming and
unbelievable as a Taekwondo star you can
take that I will take the attention of
Eagles bears Sunday afternoon wildcard
round 16 to 15 one of the most memorable
I think was a bad weekend definitely the
one reason and one reason only for that
for that parking miss at the end let's
hear the let's hear College how dramatic
it was
[Applause]
all right that's that's Al Michaels not
exactly a do you believe in miracles yes
kind of thing but Al Michaels did his
best on there let's just here look can
we can we just get the sound of the ball
hitting the crossbar because that is
hitting both crossbars to me is is
unbelievable yeah I mean that is crazy
the way we can do that right but the the
reason we're talking about this right
now is because a lot of people have
brought this up and have listened to it
is the Spanish call right so to set it
up code eparchy the Bears you know field
goal kicker going for the win
hits the upright hits the crossbar and a
lot of times it's like when this happens
it kind of becomes acute you know a
little story basically you listen to
broadcasts from all over the world like
and how excited they are in the Spanish
broadcast usually bring the noise and
this one has kind of gone viral why
don't we take a listen yeah let's take a
listen to the Spanish call yeah
[Music]
that was a Spanish call which is so much
better than Al Michaels I don't know if
you know this in Mexico both announcers
for both teams are in the booth so
you've got someone really excited and
someone really upset at the same time
kind of going back and forth but that to
me that's so much better right now it
kind of caps it captures the emotion the
drama the tragedy really in that moment
mm-hmm in the city of Chicago that that
really explained what the crowd was
feeling at them yeah it really really
through all the emotions there that yeah
that Spanish call I understand why it
why one is why does it so it so when a
play like this happens it it's almost
bigger than than just football
everyone's interested in in the reaction
to it and and one of the reactions that
got a lot of attention after the game
was actually from Kobe Bryant who in his
new role as life coach and motivator for
athletes everywhere decided to make a
statement
immediately after Kody parkis kick I'm
gonna read it to you Anthony he he said
we've all been here Cody
but if you want to win back the city you
got to get back in the lab and have a
historic season next year to bury this
one I'm happy for my Eagles nation but
as a fellow pro athlete you got a grind
harder and DoubleDown hashtag no excuses
hashtag jgs d just get done what
does he mean we've all been here okay no
one in this room has been there Kobe has
never missed a field goal in his life
he's two for two
I don't understand like it seems like
Kobe the thing he misses most about the
NBA is yelling at his teammates exactly
that he just wants to make the world his
teammates and yell at them all the time
if you think it's pathetic that I've got
my that I've got my podcast producer in
my top five friends Kobe has no friends
Kobe has it Kobe's one diamond ring away
from having nothing alright he got that
wife back with the ring he started a
podcast just so you could yell at your
best friend and one of your top five
friends I don't really yell at you I
just kind of try to I just try to help
you along
I like though that Kobe Bryant in this
new era where he's speaking to a lot of
teams like he spoke to the Chargers he
spoke to the Eagles like he has made a
new career out of being a motivator in
an asshole which seems insane to me
because every teammate he ever played
with hated playing for him I just like
imagining him at home like waiting for
the next sports tragedy to happen so he
can immediately jump up and just say no
excuses like get back in the lab start
working harder like that's
that's it my role is that like he's just
waiting for someone to script somewhere
so he can yell at them he's the scariest
sports dad in the world to him he's like
the guy in the bleachers embarrassing
himself but he does it universally like
he just goes around yelling who wants
this do you think do you think that do
you think the park is like thanks Kobe
basically thanks for the shout like but
nobody would if you're like Coco be like
guys we're doing a podcast Kobe's gonna
come in before and talk to you about it
we don't be like oh no you no matter how
even if it's like pumped you up again
you don't want that you don't want that
at all it's it's a mistake
[Music]
you